Duchamp's great ambition was a very, very bold one.
It wasn't how to be a better artist, it was
how to redefine the question
of what is it to be an artist.
He himself said in an interview that probably
his greatest contribution, among many, to
the art of that century was the idea of the
“readymade.”
A readymade work of art is something that
Duchamp came up with in the teens, nineteen-teens.
And it was the idea that literally he could
go to a store, choose an item, or maybe a
couple of items, and put them together, set
it up in his studio, and call it a work of art.
This means that all of these notions that
had gone for centuries, with the idea of an
artist, such as that you were a skilled painter
or that you knew how to carve or to mold,
all of these ideas associated with the beauty
of a creation or with the suddenness of inspiration
are gone.
He, of course, was a painter when he started
out.
First making impressionist pictures.
Then after Picasso led the way with Cubism,
he made a variety of cubist paintings.
After he had been painting for about a decade,
he decided, "You know, what's the point if
I'm one more very good or even excellent painter?
I'm not changing the world."
He bought a bicycle wheel and a kitchen stool,
put them together, the wheel on top of the
stool, and kept it in his studio.
And from time to time, he would rotate the
wheel.
One of the first readymades he made when he
got to New York, where he was encountering
snow, was a work that he called "In Advance
of the Broken Arm."
Oftentimes, the readymades had a title that
was part of the work of art.
Bought it at a hardware store on the Upper
West Side, took it to his studio, hung it up.
That was a readymade.
People, what should I say, tend to romanticize
quite a bit the meaning.
What's the choice behind the wheel and the
stool?
Is it sedentary and motion?
Is it round and round?
You can go on and on, and it brings out some
really, kind of almost like parodies of what
art historians or critics might say.
But Duchamp maintained that it wasn't a matter
of aesthetics and that it really was a matter
of the artist's brain.
And when he said that this was one of his
greatest contributions, if not his greatest,
to the art of the century, I think what he
was going for was the idea that all of this
took away the artist's or the viewer's retina
as the most important thing.
And Duchamp called painting “retinal art,”
and it was sort of like it was all about what
you would see with brush stroke and color.
Duchamp is trying to say retinal is substituting
a lot for just dumbness.
Almost like religion is the opiate of the
people.
Let's get away from that and let's get some
ideas going.
This one is called "Why Not Sneeze, Rose Sélavy?"
Its title is a question.
Rose Sélavy was his pseudonym, his female
alter ego name.
Totally puzzling question, "Why not sneeze?"
What we've got is a birdcage with some marble
sugar cubes, a cuttlefish bone, and a little
thermometer—put together all of these store
bought items, put together in a collage of objects.
When you see readymades from place to place
in various museums, I think almost virtually
none of them, just a very few, maybe a handful,
survived from the teens themselves
or the early '20s.
And thereafter, what you're seeing most everywhere
else are re-editions of them that he made
in the '40s, '50s, or '60s.
The '50s and '60s were a time that he actually
made them anew, in part because this is after
a couple of decades of relative non-celebrity,
his art became of great interest to young artists again.
People like Jasper Johns, Robert Rauschenberg
became fascinated by the model of an artist
who was not just concerned with craft and
with the idea of hard work, but who just liked
the idea that an idea could be a work of visual
art.
With pop art, with minimal art, and with what
we now have come to call conceptual art in
the 1960s, all of this depended, to an immense
degree, on the precedent of Duchamp in the
teens, having said to the world, "What matters
for a work of art is what's going on
the choices that are being made, the decision
that an artist makes.
Then he declares, or she declares, something
to be a work of art, as an idea, as a concept.
And that's all that it needs, in fact, to
be a work of art."
And it's amazing.
When I go on tours through these galleries,
with visitors, they're looking at all kinds
of abstract, pretty difficult-to-decipher
paintings on canvas
and they're taking it really well.
When we come to here, still 100 years later,
invariably I get “why is that art?”
And I think that's one of the great tributes
to Duchamp having succeeded at what he was
setting out to do.
He got people to question what otherwise is
something that they just take for granted
without a second thought.